going from a DC hero to a Marvel villain
is not an easy move to make but one
actor who can no doubt pull it off has
got to be Christian Bale right well
bails been confirmed to be playing a
villain in the upcoming Thor love and
thunder film so let's talk about which
character he might be right now on the
ketchup Thor love and thunder the fourth
film in Marvel Studios as Thor franchise
is due out in November of next year and
one of the film's co-stars Tessa
Thompson recently confirmed in an
interview with Entertainment Tonight
that Oscar winner Christian Bale will
indeed be joining the cast as a villain
they know me he will of course be in
rare company joining Michael Keaton as
someone who has played both a villain
for Marvel and a hero for DC and not
just any hero they were both Batman and
for you trivia nerds out there don't
forget that before he was Marvel's
Thanos and cable Josh Brolin also once
played Jonah Hex for DC a role that he's
not super stoked about in hindsight
Jonah acts yeah I'd go back I could more
if I'd morph into an eraser hit erase it
now rumors surrounding the Christian
Bale news are that he will play an
intergalactic or otherworldly type of
characters so let's take a look at some
of the possibilities based on past our
comics and what has been popular with
fans starting with gore the god butcher
so gore is an alien from an unknown
planet that is popped up in a few comics
most recently Jason Aaron's King Thor
miniseries he's basically a serial
killer for deities so he would
definitely make a good bad guy for Thor
another strong option could be Daario
agar the CEO of the Wroxton energy
corporation who has similarities to a
couple rolls from veils past like
Patrick Bateman from American Psycho and
Bruce Wayne but he can turn into a giant
Minotaur which is freaky plus he was one
of the central villains during Jane
Foster's run as Thor in the comics which
fits well with Natalie Portman sponser
character returning to the franchise to
pick up the hammer some other villains
that Bale could pull off include Kolb
Orson created in 2011 as the ass
guardian god of fear and magog a monster
born of the hatred of a billion beings
created a long time ago in the Thor
comics by Jack Kirby and Stan Lee stop
trying to scare us
there's also beta ray bill who
originally began as an adversary to Thor
before eventually becoming an ally which
could be an interest
strategy to keep bail in the MCU and
shout-out to our Facebook fan group
member Hamza who suggested Mephisto a
classic Thor villain from the 70s that
is considered a class 2 demon or hell
Lord so you know scary AF and you may
remember Mephisto from the Nicolas Cage
Ghost Rider movies classic Cage
[Music]
some of our followers on social media
have also thrown out the name Adam
warlock who was another old-school
character that according to Marvel chief
Kevin Feige will be a part of the Marvel
cosmic universe and may have been teased
in guardians of the galaxy vol two's and
credits scene which actually makes total
sense because Vin Diesel let it slip
recently that the guardians will be in
the new Thor film as well so mind blown
and don't forget with the Loki TV series
coming to Disney Plus next spring there
is a very good chance that that will
also tie-in to love and thunder I know
this is all very exciting so it is time
for us to kick it over to you now are
you excited to see Christian Bale in the
MCU and what villain would you like to
see him play let us know in the comments
and for more movie and TV news check out
Rotten Tomatoes calm you got your back
and remember to join our fan group on
Facebook because your comments could
appear on future episodes just like this
one and if you don't want to miss out on
any future episodes of the show hit that
subscribe button and notification bell
as always thank you for watching the
catch up I'm NASA Prez and we'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
you